If you've taken a Udacity class before, you've probably seen the Udacity IDE--well, IDE.
It's a webpage where you can enter arbitrary Python functions
and Python commands and execute them.
For instance, we can have it say hello for some wrong and then we get the output hello.
Let us now write a function which implements the finite state machine we just seen
in order to remove HTML markup.
We have the tag variable, which tells us which state we're in,
and we have an out variable, which tells us what the output would be.
Here's an implementation of the finite state machine.
If we see the beginning of an HTML tag, we set the tag variable to two, so we go into tag mode.
If we see the end of HTML markup, we set tag to false, so we exit tag mode.
Otherwise, for all other characters, we add them to the output unless we're in tag mode.
And finally, we return the output. Here's the input we just saw.
We have a bold HTML tag, we have a foo as text,
and we have an end-of-bold HTML markup in here.
If all works well, then we should get just foo as the output
and all the HTML markup should be removed.
So we take on run and we get foo as the output--that is I removed HTML markup function,
has properly stripped the bold and unbold markup from the input.